far cry 6's story was
surprisingly good i had numerous doubts
about this game going into it and
despite some of them being true this
game but more importantly for the sake
of today's video its story was really
good so today i'm gonna be spending a
bit of time talking strictly about the
game's story there's probably news
outlets and other individuals who have
already covered a more official review
about everything the game has to offer
so if you want to watch those videos you
can as today will just be focusing on
its narrative however before we get
started three quick formalities are in
order the most obvious one being a
spoiler warning because we'll be talking
about the entirety of the main story and
if you don't want it spoiled i highly
recommend you come back after you beat
the game second a huge thank you to the
people over at ubisoft for providing me
with the code to far cry 6 early so i
could get this out in a somewhat timely
fashion and thirdly i'll be using she
her pronouns to describe dany as i
played the female version after hearing
dialogue from both male and female i
just thought female danny fit a lot
better and was a whole lot better to
play in the game so i'll just be
addressing her as she rather than he but
just keep in mind i'll still be talking
about danny with that out of the way
let's get started firstly we need to
cover the very basics of the game to set
the scene thankfully this was all shown
during the introduction yaro which is
basically a fictional version of cuba
was under the rule of a dictator who was
anton's father around 13 anton saw his
father executed in front of his own eyes
and eventually 47 years later yara was
now under anton's control another
castillo and another dictator but thanks
to a miraculous discovery yara has the
potential to now prosper as a country
thanks to something called the viviro a
drug that can cure cancer except it's
built on the back of slaves our role in
this game is a person named dany she's a
native yaran living in the country when
the government is putting a stop to a
recent riot she sees one of her closest
friends die and then they sprint through
the streets trying to get to a nearby
refugee ship until it's stopped by anton
the ship is shot up but somehow she's
the only survivor she washes up on a
nearby beach next to her other dying
friend and meets clara the leader of
liberta a group about to start a
revolution against castillo i was
skeptical about this game originally i
wasn't even going to buy the game
ubisoft has a history of having a
consistent formula in its games and
recently has started blending those
games together to where they start to
feel like the same genre of game just
slightly different mechanics and
location far cry 6 in comparison to its
predecessors is really no different
besides small changes in the occasional
overhaul across the series every game
from far cry 3 to 6 can almost be seen
as the same game i understand that's not
entirely true but it's also not entirely
false either this formula is wonderful
but terrible at the same time because if
someone likes the consistency of the
formula and doesn't want to deviate from
it they're gonna love all the games they
produce but if someone wants something
different they'll have to look elsewhere
this not only relates to far cry's
gameplay but also its story we get a
brief moment to see our protagonist the
antagonist and the protagonist meet they
have a rivalry then they duke it out at
the end however far cry 6 attempts to
change this formula far cry has seen two
evolutions in its series across the
games the evolution of the antagonist
but also the de-evolution of our
protagonist we went from having two
named protagonists with motivations and
personalities being jason and aj to the
deputy of far cry 5 faceless nameless
and mute the intention being that we can
put ourselves into this character we are
the deputy but it doesn't feel the same
i preferred controlling a named person
and watching the story unfold rather
than become a part of the story i talked
a lot about this in my video a few
months ago on the far cry villain so if
you do want to see that stick around to
the end of this video or you could just
go to the link down below but even
though in far cry 6 we got a named
protagonist i was still skeptical but
ubisoft surprised me by not only adding
a protagonist with some of the best
personality in the series but also
continued to really push this idea that
they are a real person with real
interactions and real ideas not some
random faceless person the player
controls the game finally introduced
third person cutscenes so now we can see
our character and all their expressions
and actions and its full glory and on
top of that dany is extremely likable i
still prefer jason and his classic white
american never really had a bad day in
his life personality as that conflicts
with the environment he's put in but
danny's a close second her expressions
coupled with her bilingual speaking
skills make her all the more likeable
one thing that truly amazed me was that
danny can actually sing along to the
radio depending on the song it might be
small to some but i loved it she's a
native to yara so it only makes sense
that she can speak the language and know
the culture and ubisoft continued to
reinforce that idea but they weren't
done with these changes for the first
time in a while our introduction to the
protagonist wasn't a wrong place wrong
time scenario if jason ever went
partying on a foreign island he wouldn't
have been captured if aj played along
with pagan or maybe went at a different
time he wouldn't have been swept up in
this mess if the deputy never joined the
others he wouldn't have been a major
character in the game either danny
wasn't at the wrong place at the wrong
time she was born in the wrong place
everything went to [ __ ] before we even
started the game she's lived in yara her
whole life and she was just in the wrong
place since birth it's a very different
way to introduce a character that we
haven't seen done yet and it's also the
first time we have a character who's
native and familiar with the land we're
in the only person that could also
belong in that description is the deputy
is seeing as he was stationed at hope
county but it doesn't really help much
since he doesn't talk danny and the
other people she meets with all talk
about their times in yara all the things
they did when they were young and they
talk about all the locations in the game
like they're familiar with them because
they are another change was danny's
motivation when i play story games i try
to break them as much as i can in the
context of backstory i've done this
quite a bit when creating characters in
d and d so i created a character that
wants to go adventuring the biggest
question is why to relate this to far
cry 6 why deviate from your original
gold to do something else for danny the
moment she gets on the beach she says
that she wants to go to miami and leave
the island so my first thought is how
are they going to convince us that dandy
changed her ideals and now attempts to
start a revolution honestly it's not
clear and specific for the sake of
gameplay but what i have come up with is
that because dany has a background in
weapons as she was once a soldier she
decided to help clara in the beginning
as they have a mutual agreement if dany
does this job for her clara gets her a
boat and dany helps her take back one of
the islands and once she's helped her
and realize that she is skilled enough
to take on a small island mostly by
herself it might be enough to convince
her that she is capable of winning this
revolution whether or not you believe
that is up to you but more importantly
the game never took away her original
plan after taking back the tutorial
island you can actually leave when clara
gives you the boat and it goes into the
secret ending danny's relaxing on the
miami beach clara is dead and anton is
still in power even though it's the bad
ending it goes back to the beginning
scene where she was originally wanting
to get on the boat off the island it's
obviously not an official ending because
then we wouldn't have a game but it's
nice that they continue to keep that in
the game anyway the last and arguably
most important part is diego and anton
for the first time in a while the
protagonist and the antagonist do not
have a history with one another this
isn't some personal relationship they
built from the beginning it's a dictator
and a revolutionary you don't run into
anton like you do the others that often
besides the end of the game you only run
into him two times once during the intro
and once during a mission with juan
after conquering majority of the island
ready to start the final mission i'd had
only seen him in person with dany twice
whereas in the other games this would be
the fourth fifth or sixth time i've been
seeing them we become a persistent
[ __ ] hell-bent on defeating them but
to anton or just another person in his
revolution but then there's also diego
because there are now two important
characters on the opposing side time
needs to be split between them so we
ended up getting less time with the
antagonist than usual far cry games but
it played off as diego was arguably my
favorite character in the game and the
most important character in this game
the fact that diego exists in the game
at all is a complete curveball in the
past games once you kill the antagonist
the game is over technically this isn't
true as vas isn't the last villain you
can choose to let pagan go and joseph
isn't really dead but you get my point
we all knew from the very beginning we
would have a final showdown with our
antagonist and the game would be over
soon after diego changes that diego is a
13 year old boy and the next heir to
yara yes he doesn't agree with his dad's
ideas but anton has kept a tight leash
around him and it's never really clear
what the hell he wants mostly because he
hasn't been given the option to do so
one moment he's pointing a gun at us
then xe's trying to save us he's
confusing us because he's confused
himself he doesn't know what he wants
and that means we the player don't know
what to do about him there were so many
theories i had about diego while playing
i was thinking that maybe diego would
die because libertad sees him as the
enemy maybe we could choose to save
diego maybe diego after seeing his
family killed becomes like his father or
maybe he's stronger than that and knows
how to run the country properly or maybe
since it's clear that clara has her eyes
set on the throne maybe we have to
choose between diego or clara it was
rattling my brain from the very
beginning but it's clear that because of
his existence this ending could go in
any direction which is the main reason i
wanted to finish this game's story now
that we're done with that incredibly
long talk let's talk about the rest of
the game this game functions like far
cry 5 where we have three key areas to
conquer before going after the leader
these areas are maduraga vale de oro and
el este each of these areas is under
siege between anton's forces and some
other militia groups clara wants to
recruit them to liberta because if the
four groups can co-exist together then
they can defeat anton farcry once again
gives you the option to go wherever you
want to first i personally went to
madaraga first since it was the closest
and definitely not for any other reason
but this area is under the control of
jose castillo the nephew of anton and we
can join a group called the monteros el
este is controlled by admiral benitez
and a politician named sean mckay here
we can join up with a group called la
morale who works with the legends of 67
the leaders of the past revolution who
overthrew anton's father and lastly vale
de oro was under the control of maria
marquessa and as we discover later dr
edgar reyes and we joined a group of
ragtag people called maximus mantanzas
so three areas and three different
groups this means it's three different
experiences later in valle de oro we can
also discover each role of the island
maduraga is where the crops and tobacco
plants are grown for viviro valede oro
is where v vero is packaged and produced
and ls day is where the chemical pg-240
is made which creates viviro each area
has a role in the production of this
drug so each area has a unique leader to
kill a unique group to recruit and on
the other side of the coin a unique role
for producing viviro on the island this
was wonderful as it didn't feel like the
same [ __ ] from one area to the next
each group has a different reason they
exist and different boundaries to
overcome and the island has different
roles in its production of viviro so not
only are we seeing three unique areas
the missions were related to these areas
we're not just destroying tobacco farms
all game we're sabotaging production
plants and destroying propaganda
depending on where we are and it was
extremely well thought out dialing it
back a bit though these groups were
quite unique and entertaining although
the only one i didn't really like was
the monteros the other two especially
maximus montanzas was incredible each
had a ton of likable people and at least
one person being the comic relief
maximus montanzas however was easily my
favorite as they took down the area's
leader differently than the others both
monteros and la morale can be seen as
militia groups shooting and killing
their way to victory but for talia
apollo and bicho they just wanted to
create some music their aries leader was
maria marquessa who runs huge propaganda
campaigns for anton so why not beat her
at her own game and not kill her but
embarrass her it's not enough just to
remove the current leader from an area
you need to make the people living there
feel free and encourage them to do their
part and join the revolution and that's
what this group's job was each group had
a sort of large moment where the climax
came in for the monteros it was the
assassination of jose castillo for la
morale and the leaders of 67 it was the
assault on admiral benitez's fort but
for maximus mantanzos it was performing
a concert while we defended them from
waves of enemies it was unique and
magnificent each one of them in this
group is extremely likable and had their
own motives and personalities and it was
even great to see those motives and
personalities come to light in the
game's missions paulo wanted to leave
the island like danny did back in the
intro and since paolo left halia was
quite emotional and unstable about it
which led her to do drastic things like
murdering maria she was on an
unstoppable rampage paulo was gone and
bicho's drinking his sorrows away
because this radio group they built
together was gone before it barely
started this game taps into this by
having you bring paolo back which leads
into a ton of cutscenes and dramatic
moments like meeting the doctor and
creator of viviro almost dying from the
disease itself because of him because
it's not a far cry game if you aren't
drugged for an entire mission and saving
bicho from attempting to murder bembe
that's of course not to say the other
two groups are bad but maximus montanzas
was clearly different from the other two
and the way they went about getting
their area was a whole different
experience compared to the other two
groups and it was wonderful earlier i
said anton didn't get a lot of screen
time compared to the other antagonists
of the series whether that was because
they hired an a-list actor who was
probably quite expensive to cast or was
intentional from the beginning it didn't
matter giancarlo did a wonderful job in
this role anton is menacing when he's on
screen and there are tons of incredible
things he says throughout the game some
of which make a lot of sense every time
a major event happens like the ones
previously discussed we get a short cut
scene of anton and diego one time
diego's practicing his shooting the
other time he's sitting down talking
with his dad this is not only a really
good way of seeing the other side of our
actions but also seeing the characters
develop as we go on anton is a dictator
he is not only there for a reason but he
has kept a hold of yara this long for a
reason he is smart and he is well versed
in military strategy and political
strategy for example during the fight
with the monteros the leader carlos was
killed during the battle jose wanted to
surprise anton with this news but he's
less than excited
your cousin seeks praise
if i knew his plan i would have told him
that the montero roots
run deep in the farmlands two
hundred years
uncle i was trying to surprise you diego
how many of your uncle's soldiers come
from devanas
80 papa correct
and now
he has made a martyr of the most famous
montero
let's see how many of his soldiers
want to rebuild paradise now this is not
only a showcase of his knowledge and
military strategy but his strategy to
recruit and boost the morale of the yarn
people but by far the best was during
the interview with him i don't want to
explain too much so just listen let's
talk viviro
a cancer treatment that extends the
lives of millions around the world
except in the united states my own
father is stage four why do you make
americans wait it's very american to
expect what does not belong to you you
refuse diplomatic overtures even
promises to lift the blockade
i am sorry about your father but
americans will wait
just like everyone else yesterday your
network yarovision was hijacked by
rebels they called for the liberation of
so-called outcasts from viviro labor
camps is viviro produced with slave
labor truth or lies the truth of course
yada did not write the playbook
slavery was your first corporation 1800
to 1860 cotton was your number one
export grown by whom just a second
slaves
four million americans worth 3.5 billion
dollars it was people who look like me
what is that called a history lesson a
head start
replaced by a billion dollar prison
industry that pays its inmates pennies
america is not alone correct
children so are close
sweatshops build our phones and bibiro
saves millions of lives do you think
that those lives care where it comes
from
that line do you think that those lives
care where it comes from is incredibly
powerful and completely true just like
most of what he said yara's prospering
because of the work of slaves like how
the united states was built on the back
of slaves and slave labor is nothing new
like anton said america wrote the
playbook we're just as guilty as he is
even the line i brought up before is
true i don't really care or want to look
into the potential ramifications of my
purchases if i need clothes i'm gonna
buy them just like when i need a new
iphone i'm going to buy it and most
people don't give a [ __ ] about the
production of the product only the
outcome of that production these are my
favorite types of villains ones that
have goals or ideas that are quite
agreeable or ones who do bad things for
the sake of doing something good as it
makes you redraw the line of whether or
not they're an actual villain or not in
anton's case he's a mix of both i
understand his intentions though by
creating viviro he could help the future
of yara but the present yaro is going to
suffer because of it anton to me is a
welcome member of the far cry antagonist
and fits right in he reminds me a lot of
pagan actually in his decisions that i
once again discussed in my previous far
cry video he brings up that he justified
his actions because his daughter died
the same way aj justified all his
merciless killings throughout the game
because his mom's wish was to be buried
in kirat both these villains make you
think about your decisions and anton's
questioning doesn't even stop at one
simple line it's reinforced throughout
the whole game it's one thing to take
back yara but the real fight is after
once anton is dead yara is free but now
it's a war-torn country barely hanging
on it needs a leader in a political
structure or it's no better if not worse
than anton's regime this is why towards
the end of lsd that politician sean
mckay strikes a deal with juan who was
going to give him money so that he could
be free when the revolution is done
everyone will be dirt poor jobless some
people even homeless it's going to be a
mess so by accepting this offer we could
fund the government we want to build for
the future but mckay goes free so it's a
choice and one that took me lots of time
to decide on all these thoughts and
decisions the player has to make lead to
the ending the one thing everyone is
focused on what is going to happen to us
to anton to diego to libertad to yara
what is going to happen and to quickly
summarize my thoughts i was quite
satisfied with the ending the ending
starts around that point of no return
section of games as usual we have
eliminated all the opposition and taken
most of yara back while we did lose some
people along the way we are finally
ready to take the country back but some
prior knowledge is very relevant here
once we defeat the doctor we get a
cutscene that shows anton about to make
a quick announcement to the people of
yara about the doctor's death but we see
him attached to an iv it's clear that he
needs a blood transfusion of some kind
so it's assumed that his health is
declining back to the mission once it
starts we get a call from juan claire
has been captured as she took the
meeting with anton a little earlier in
the game this was hinted at when danny
and clara met back at the orphanage but
she surprisingly took anton up on his
offer but it was a very stupid decision
as she has now played into his hands and
is captured at his private island so
while juan finds a suitable spot for the
assassination we infiltrate the compound
posing as a soldier so we can rescue
clara it's also here where lots of [ __ ]
goes down
stop staring
sit
dani
sit down
my mother had a rule
no lies at my table
and so
no lies for you
i have acute leukemia
i was diagnosed 13 years ago
but there was a doctor
he promised what we are all so desperate
for
time
but it wasn't enough
was it diego papa i don't want to hear
the story i needed insurance
but the irony was
i hated kiss
but maria
maria she had a way with worse
and
here you are
13 years
strong and what happened next diego
the veto stopped working when six months
ago
no lies at my table
i will be gone
but
he will see the vision through
won't you
truth or lies
always truth you're a [ __ ] monster ah
i think that was truth
danny
watch my little firefly dance
you know when i capture clara
i thought i had one
but it took
my son to show me what was right before
my eyes
you
you are libertad i'm just taking no lies
at my table
you're a legend they tell stories about
you come on
you are their hope and now you will
become my hope you're kidding right
you still don't get it i told you to
leave this is your fault you want her to
live you will accept the right my army
you would be
my hope my legend my danny rojas
why are you so obsessed with dividing us
through yarans fake your aunts it's one
[ __ ] yara let us pick our own future
you're just some sick
dying old man
a new poor kid your brain must be so
[ __ ] up with his poison no eyes on
anton i'm taking out the kid
who are you talking to i'm taking the
shot
this is truly a wild scene the camera
angles the close-ups everything about
this was executed wonderfully anton's
eyes also look different in this scene
and i can't tell if it's because he's
going blind or not but regardless he
definitely doesn't look good at all his
whole plan was because he was diagnosed
with acute leukemia he didn't have
enough time to see his vision of yara
come true so he had a kid with maria
even though he didn't like kids so that
diego could run the country when he dies
he didn't create a life out of want but
out of necessity diego's whole backstory
is completely messed up and we could see
the impact it has on him he's a 13 year
old boy with no childhood and no way out
of the situation he was put in from
birth anton wasn't just hurting the
people of his country but his own son
that he didn't even want to begin with
it's probably the best cut scene in the
game and one that has to be played out
in full to really showcase the true
power behind it back to the game it's
clear things have gone to [ __ ] and we
need to leave immediately danny catches
up with juan and argues about diego and
this is where that division comes in let
me know in the comments who you relate
to i agree with danny diego was just the
kid who got caught up in the wrong stuff
but i'm wondering if some of you may
agree with juan who he's just a kid but
diego's a castillo and he needs to be
killed dany is now the leader of liberta
and leads all the groups she has
recruited throughout the story to
initiate the final assault on castillo
the battle of esperanza was a wonderful
mission and the soundtrack playing
behind the fighting is really motivating
and matches the theme of this mission
and everything it stands for tons of
guards are here and after we clear them
going floor to floor up castillo's tower
we finally reach the top
he's about the same age i was when you
got a yes murdered my father
i never thought that you would have to
face what they put me through
i am sorry diego
you are my lion
everything that i did
i did
to make you stronger
you are not going to kill him
he's going to die anyway
last lesson meal
there is one thing in life that will
always be true
do you know what that is
death
see
you will protect it
from your friends
from the monsters
he'll be safe i promise
lies
honestly that's not at all what i
thought was going to happen truly that
was quite the shock i figured someone
was going to die but the way it happened
was definitely not the way i expected
everything about this part of the game
was great i just wish diego was given
the option to actually do something i
wanted diego to speak his feelings show
us what he actually wants instead of
just muttering a few words every now and
then but maybe that was actually the
point maybe it was to show that he will
never understand what he wants because
of anton he is essentially ruined diego
from birth and he's never going to
recover let me know what you think about
that in the comments below i wish we got
more stuff regarding diego but even with
what we have i'm completely satisfied i
figured far cry wasn't going to shy away
from having an indiscernible ending in
the context of good or bad since these
endings usually go both ways but i never
expected what we saw during the ending
we aren't done though since there is a
small after credit scene that is only
audio where juan and some smuggler are
doing a drug trade it seems that juan is
selling viviro across the border to make
a large amount of money for himself i'm
unsure how to interpret this but the
only thing i can come up with is that
juan doesn't really care about yara and
he only did the revolution to make a
quick buck which is quite selfish but
maybe i'm looking at it wrong regardless
though this does bring us to the end of
far cry 6 and equally to the end of this
video far cry 6 in regards to its story
was really well done and surprisingly
was able to twist my ideas about this
series quite fast as stated in the intro
with a video i was skeptical about even
buying this game but the writers really
took some big strides in keeping things
consistent but also attempting to branch
out into other ideas of storytelling
like its third person cutscenes
charismatic protagonist and the addition
of its third-party character in the form
of diego far cry 6 is a great game and
in terms of its story i recommend it
anton has a lot of competition as this
game is filled with brilliantly made
villains but i think he fits in
perfectly but now we've actually come to
the end of the video thank you all for
watching today as i've said numerous
times before i did do a character
analysis on vos pagan and joseph so if
you do want to hear me talk about them
for about 30 minutes that'll be linked
down below but also with the end card
coming up in a couple moments if you
want to see more videos like this feel
free to check out any of my other
previous videos like my analysis of
fallout new vegas or death loop and of
course if you're new then subscribe for
more content like this in the future and
if you're a returning viewer i thank you
for coming back take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
you